want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some fire
motivation
from kobe bryant
there's a choice we have to make as
people as individuals if you want to be
great at something
you have to make inherent sacrifices
that come along with that family time
hanging out with your friends so at the
age of 18
i knew that i was not going to be
stopped this was my life
we all can be masters at our craft but
you have to make sacrifices that come
along with making that decision
follow your passion first first first
first first first
um when i retired from the game
and i said they're asking kind of all
the wrong questions you know what's the
biggest
industry i can get into and it's all the
wrong stuff
and you got to sit there and ask
yourself okay what am i truly passionate
about what do i enjoy
doing and when you feel that way i
honestly i mean you feel like you have
never worked a day in your life it's the
most fun thing in the world you get up
in the morning excited about what you're
doing
and you got to be really honest with
yourself about it if you wake up in the
morning and you're dreading going to
work dude do something else
do something else and those are hard
decisions to make but when you make
those decisions
it's a very liberating experience and
you find out that the rewards will come
when i played one of the things i had to
learn is how to get the best out of my
teammates
yeah and most people think it's a simple
thing you know passing the ball
you know but that's not how you make
guys better you have to really affect
their behavior how do you do that so
yeah like
i would tell guys you know we got back
to backs
you know i don't care if we're in miami
i don't care if we're in a great city or
chicago
you can't go out we gotta get rest right
back-to-back games back-to-back games
right monday tuesday play monday and
play again tuesday
you guys aren't gonna listen right
you're gonna you're right so a few times
all right we'll all go out go out
together
really i'll drink with you right but the
next morning i'm banging on your door at
five in the morning
let's go they're not getting where are
we going
i hung out with you now you come hang
out with me wow this is what we do all
right let's go
they're at the gym we're working out
right we hit the bus we go to practice
we play that night
and they're dead and they're dead
they're like lesson learned
take them out once listen if you're
going to do that do that
but don't let that compromise what we're
here to do right this is why we're here
this is why you're here in the first
place
yeah right and if we're going to win a
championship we have to have that
championship mentality
work ethic that's it so you got to show
them no kobe can do that and still has
the energy to get up and do this so
either i got to meet that same energy or
i got to keep my butt more early
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below or to go play
someplace else to try to chase a
championship that's not me man
that's not being that's not what my
career has been about we all can be
masters at our craft but you have to
make sacrifices that come along with
making that decision
you start with what do you want your
game to be
what would make your game most
unstoppable
my philosophy was a very simple one i um
and this is where i think film plays a
big part of my life i
you know rudy was one of my favorite
films growing up after watching that
film
i come to understand if i could work
that hard
every day with the
being blessed with the physical tools
that i have
what would my career be and i made a
promise to myself
from that day that i was going to work
that hard
every single day so that when i do
retire
i have no regrets and that was the most
important thing for me is to leave no
stone unturned
get better every single day and if i
lived that way then
over time you know i'd have something
that was beautiful
but that was my philosophy it seems like
a pretty simple one but
you know if you live your life to just
get better every single day
and do that for 20 years i mean what do
you have here's why
practice was important to me not from
just the standpoint that i enjoyed
playing like i enjoyed being there
i enjoy getting better but as a leader
of a team
it's also your responsibility to elevate
the rest of the guys
and what people tend to get stuck on a
lot
saying okay the way to make players
better
is to pass them the ball when they're
open that's a very trivial
way to look at things what you have to
do is you have to get them
emotionally to want to be better
you want you have to get them to an
emotional space where they wake up
every morning driven to be the best
version of themselves
right how do you do that and in practice
for me it was a chance to drive them
to challenge them right if they're and
this is where you have to know your
teammates
because if it's late we just had a back
to back and we had practice the next day
and you show up
and guys don't feel like going through
the motions don't feel like practicing
it's important to know each and every
one of them
individually personally because then you
know what nerve to touch
some guys it's like okay come on let's
you know we can do this that'll get them
going
other guys know you got to figure out
what button to push
you know pow was always spain
if i tell them how they lost in a gold
medal to us and how they're going to
lose again
how i'm going to beat your ass in
practice just like i beat you in a gold
medal game oh that oh he would hate that
he'd hate that but that's what practice
was you have to drive them you
absolutely have to
and if practice is more intense and
harder than a game seven will be
then a game seven will be easy but if
it's not then that's when teams start
folding and capitulating
once you have the passionate thing that
you're passionate about now you can look
at
other people or other entities or other
things or works of art and you can draw
things from that
to help you be better at what you do by
looking for those common denominators
johnny wanted to know
how do i prepare how do i prepare how do
i study how do i view the game how do
you build
your game and you know my response is
much like
the way he builds products you think
sequentially
you know yeah you look at this the end
result of what you want to create but in
order to create that there's so many
other little things that go into this
massive entity or device
it's no different than building my
basketball game you start with
where you want your game to be what
would make your game
most unstoppable or hard to deal with
and now you work backwards from there
and you start building it
one piece at a time one move at a time
one counter at a time
so there's a lot of similarities there
you just gotta
have the uh the fearlessness to really
take those shots
you know because you miss those shots
then you have to deal with the
the criticism you have to deal with uh
us talking about it right right
right so you know and a lot of times a
lot of people kind of get a little
apprehensive about taking those shots
because of that
why would we mention it seems like you
started smiling already just thinking
about the word
yeah well it's it's it's always uh it's
always
been a myth to me as to why um certain
people don't really
like those situations because of the the
pressure you know because we've all lost
games before
so it's not like by you missing that
shot you're about to face something that
you will never face again or haven't
faced in the past you know what i mean
we've all come up short
at you know one time or another so um
just kind of kind of let it all hang out
and
you know trust your skills and trust the
work that you put in you know i've been
with you
for a long way i i the one moment that
stands out
out of we've done i don't know how many
done we've done what 800 events
the one time was 4 a.m we went out to
practice at 4 00
a.m and that was your idea to do it but
and then you know all these nike people
are like no
no no no let's not let's not do that and
then you're like let's do it at 4am so
you got security you got brand marketing
sports marketing going no
no no no let's not do it you're like
let's do it because that's your
accessibility
right i mean to me it just makes
complete sense not to us
but i don't like
usually i'm sleeping at 4 a.m you're
working out
so talk about that okay so if if
if your job is to try to be the best
basketball player you can be
right to do that you have to practice
you have to train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can
so if you get up at 10 in the morning
train at 11
right 12 say 12 train at 12 train for
two hours twelve to two
um you have to let your body recover so
you eat recover whatever you get back
out you train start training again at
six train from six to eight
right and now you go home you shower you
eat dinner you go to bed you wake up you
do it again right those are two sessions
right now imagine you wake up at three
you train at four go four to six
come home breakfast relax
now you're back at it again nine to
eleven
right you relax and now all of a sudden
you're back at it again two to four
and now you're back at it again you know
seven to nine
look how much more training i have done
by simply starting at four
right and so now you do that and as the
years go on
the separation that you have with your
competitors and your peers
just grows larger and larger and larger
and larger and larger
and by year five or six doesn't matter
what kind of work they do in the summer
they're never going to catch up
because they're five years behind right
so it makes sense
to get up and start your day early
because you can get more working
is that genetic or is that something you
you ingrained and trained yourself no it
really taught you that for me it was
it was just common sense like i can i
can if i start earlier i can train more
hours
and i know the other guys aren't doing
it because i know what their training
schedule is
right so i know if i do this
consistently over time
this the gap's just going to widen and
wide and why why and why
and they won't be able to get that back
so to me it was just common sense i'm
like thinking how can i get an advantage
oh
start earlier yeah let's do that how do
you how do you develop that or where do
you
where do you learn that from well i i
think it's just
you know it's just a matter of what's
important to you mm-hmm
and what's important to you for whatever
reason
you know i i felt like i didn't feel
good about myself if i wasn't
doing everything i could to be the best
version of myself
if i felt like i left anything on the
table um
it would eat away at me i wouldn't be
able to look myself in the mirror
right so the reason why i can retire now
and be completely comfortable about it
because i know that i've done
everything i could to be the best
basketball player i could be
um and so that's where it comes from for
me you can't leave any stone unturned
when you think about your risk tolerance
for failure
how far are you willing to fail well i
mean unfortunately unfortunately i
failed quite a bit
you know but i understand that's
actually part of the process of
succeeding
i'm not one that really believe in
failure i believe you have setbacks
and you know you have to learn from
those you have to learn what are those
landmines
that can be avoided the next time what
are those pitfalls you have to learn
from that stuff
and um so you're not welcome those
things it's a part of life but are you
prepared to like
really fail it's something totally new
like what if you're just pvc
yeah you know and then i work at it and
then i'm not at
vc the next yeah or you know whenever it
happens
listen i my first year in the league on
national tv
at 18 years old and i shot five straight
air balls in the playoffs in front of
millions of people
yeah i think my time is pretty high yeah
yeah
i think i'm all right the passion came
from the love for the game
you know i loved everything about it
like the smell of the ball
you love the smell of the ball yes the
ball you know the smell of like brand
new sneakers and like the sound the ball
makes when it hits the ground
sneakers in the gym yeah the ball going
through the net like all those things
i love and so the passion comes from
that because once you have that love you
just want to
be a part of this thing all the time is
there
one moment where you can say it define
your passion for basketball is there a
story or moment when you said yeah that
was
that was it that was like when i felt
really passionate
no i it doesn't it never leaves it never
leaves like
you know the game is just a part of me
um
so it never leaves even now that i'm
retired you know
everything that i've learned from the
game of basketball i've carried it over
into life
you know like basketball's helped me be
a better person a better friend a better
house
well because there's life lessons that
are within the game like communication
like unselfishness um like attention to
detail
and um empathy and compassion like all
those things are in the game
and uh as an athlete if we are aware of
those things
um it helps us become better human
human beings and you can apply that
toward
your post post basketball days your
retirement
into your business world future ventures
sure i mean you can play you know i was
applying that
um even while i was playing just in life
outside of the game
and even more so now you know in
building a business and all these things
you know the kind of culture you want to
have um
you know all those things are
directly uh learned from the game of
basketball for me
when i injured my achilles and it became
something where it's okay this is
this is immediate the end of my career
could be now
so since i was 21 years old and thinking
okay i have to figure out what comes
next
you kind of brainstorm you ideate but
you never really
execute anything and when the injury
happened it's like okay no i need to
start
building now right and that's when the
turning point was for me
when i'm sitting there and i have the
achilles injury um
it's one thing to sit there and try to
block out the frustrations of being
injured because that's you're constantly
tugging
with that right as opposed to simply
replacing that
with a new challenge right something
that gets you excited so now you're not
focused on
not being depressed you're focused on
the excitement of building something new
and so uh it was extremely exciting man
having to figure something out and
build it from the ground up do you want
to be known
long-term as kobe bryant the storyteller
and business person who happened to be a
basketball player
or the basketball player who had a uh
successful career thereafter you know it
depends who you talk to i mean
talking to you well i'm saying if you
ask that question to a writer who's
never seen a basketball game before i
would love to be known as a kick-ass
storyteller right
right if you talk to an athlete that
doesn't like reading a book for anything
then i like to be known as a phenomenal
basketball player right
personally i would love to be both
because i am both right
you can't shelf one for the other i mean
the game has brought me to where i am
today
um you know the investment platform the
brian steibel platform the storytelling
that we're doing is going to put me
where i will be 20 years from now we
really want to create something that is
epic
and the patience
of making sure every detail is cared for
um making sure you're hitting the proper
beats from a plot perspective
right you know the patience the detail
so hopefully we can create something
that is absolutely epic and timeless
and if it isn't timeless honestly we
won't put it out you know when we put it
out it's because we believe that it is
it is the best work that we can possibly
do what i try to do is just try to be
still
and understand that things come and go
emotions come and go the important thing
is to
accept them all to embrace them all
and then you can choose to do with them
which you want
versus being controlled by emotion
you know a lot of times i've seen
players even myself you know when i was
younger
being consumed by a particular fear
and to the point where you're saying
okay nah it's it's not good to feel fear
i shouldn't be nervous in a situation
like not and it does nothing but grow
versus stepping back and saying yeah i
am nervous about this situation yeah i
am fearful about the situation well what
am i afraid of
and then you kind of unpack it and then
it gives you the
ability to look at it for really what it
is which is nothing more than your
imagination
running this course you know yeah
absolutely yeah i love that because what
you're saying is that when you're
dealing with something it's almost like
how can i get to the root of it
yeah because sometimes what we're
dealing with like you're saying it's an
imagination an illusion it's not really
it's not it's not really a thing yeah
you know like you think about
game-winning shots and
or game-winning free throws and people
go to the free-throw line and you're
nervous about it well what are you
really nervous about if you unpack that
okay
you're nervous that you're gonna miss
the shot all right so you missed the
shot then what happens people are gonna
be
embarrassed you're gonna be embarrassed
because thousands of people millions
people see you missed the shot
all right and then what people are gonna
talk bad about you okay
right and so you're looking at you go
are those things even important
you know what i mean if that that is my
fear like what is you worried about
letting your teammates down
okay have you let them down before well
i'm sure and practice and things of that
nature right they're still there
yeah you know and so when you're able to
unpack it you kind of look at it for
what it is which is really nothing
there's a quote from one of my english
teachers a little marian named
mr fisk he had a great quote that said
rest at the end not in the middle and
that's something i always live by
you know i'm not going to rest and i'm
going to keep on pushing now there's a
lot of answers
that i don't have even questions that i
don't have
but i'm just going to keep going it's
going to keep going and i'll figure
these things
out as you go right and you just
continue to build that way so that i try
to live by that all the time
rest at the end rest at the end dreams
is uh they should be pure
and i think a lot of times when we're
born into this world we actually wound
up going backwards
and it seems like the more we mature
the more responsible our dreams become
and the more governors we put on
ourselves and our ability to dream
and to reimagine and it's always a fight
for his parents and you know for you
guys to make sure that your dreams
always stay pure
and so it's not a matter of of um
of pushing beyond your limitations or
expectations
it's really a matter of protecting your
dreams protecting your imagination
that's really the key and when you do
that then the world just seems
limitless shaq's future is certain
the big shift in the balance of power in
the nba as the league's most
dominant player is headed back east the
newest member of the miami heat
remember this i'm gonna bring a
championship to miami i promise
after we split apart were you trying to
get more
more championships than me oh absolutely
you were
absolutely and i knew you were going to
get one i knew you're going to get one
because of the energy
you know going into miami and dude and
everything that was there i knew you
were going to get that one
so i knew i had to get at least two or
three and the miami heat
are champions of the basketball world
i wanted you to get that because i
needed that
i wanted that like i wanted people to
say see
see this is what they're missing here
this is what they gave up for
right kobe should have been the one to
go now he's in miami he's been
like i needed that i wanted that i
wanted everybody to hate me i wanted to
fuel off of that
and just come back with so much anger
and so much vengeance
so i wanted that so when you won right
after you won i went out to the track
and i ran
i did my conditioning i did my drills i
woke up the next morning i hit my
weights i did my thousand shots i did
everything
humanly possible to get myself ready but
i was
i needed i was alright yeah good good i
knew that
i read a quote that you said you love
business as much as basketball there's
no way that's true
it's a hundred percent true there's no
way you lo i mean basketball was your
life
your passion everything you you're
telling me you love doing business as
much
if you could you know basically snap a
finger and be
25 year old kobe or the kobe today you
wouldn't go back and keep playing
basketball
no because i've already done it see
here's the thing
when i was playing and you know
teammates would say oh kobe's not out on
the road
what is he doing you see me on the plane
he's reading what is he reading
he's writing what is he writing i'm
practicing
i'm writing i'm practicing i'm
understanding how to tell stories
i'm reading joseph campbell and how to
create arcs compelling arcs and plots
i'm reading that stuff
so this is going back 15 years right so
i don't just retire
right dear basketball and luck into
winning an oscar you know what i'm
saying yeah stuff comes from
hard work and from studying for 15 years
how to write and how to organize
structure
right and you can't do that without
having a serious love
or commitment to the craft at 13 years
old
and i played the longer game because my
game wasn't about being better than you
at 13. it was to be better than you
when you know the chips are really on on
the line
so when you played at 13 i would size
you up and see what your strengths and
weaknesses are
how do you approach the game are you
silly about it are you goofy about it
are you good at it just because you're
bigger and stronger than everybody else
right or is there actually thought and
skill that you put into it
right and when i'd play i'd played in my
weaknesses i went played in my strengths
i played in my weaknesses
because when you're playing summer
basketball there's so many games
so there's not a lot of skill work being
done so when are you going to get better
right when you're playing in competition
situations you're only playing to your
strengths why because you want to win
right so what i would do i always work
on the things during those games that i
was weak at
left hand pull up jump shot uh
post game right so i have a strategy and
so then
fast forward to when i'm 17 and my game
is completely well-rounded and that
player at 13 that i saw at 13 is still
doing the same
at 17 now you got a problem that's right
going to take us behind uh kind of the
current with michael was there ever a
moment that you guys spoke
that you felt like it energized you and
you learned from him yeah it was well it
was crazy man because my favorite player
was magic growing up
and then i quickly realized my father
stole all my height and i was gonna be a
six nine point guard so i had to
you know so look at this young guy
coming up and the thing that i marveled
at wasn't the fact that he was getting
to the rim and doing these fancy stuff
it was like how is he getting to the rim
how is he doing it
right you look at the footwork look at
the fundamentals look at the spacing
the pacing right and all those little
things the angles
and that's what becomes fascinating it's
like okay how do i get there
right so i started studying all those
basics and then when i came to the
league the first time i played against
him
um i wanted his respect because it was
like this kid's not scared of me
at all right and he saw kendrick's
spirit from that standpoint
and that started a relationship and it
became something where it was like
you know text them anytime hits me right
back
questions hits me right back and we're
talking all the time where did you get
your killer instinct from
well yeah i think a lot of it had to do
with um
isolation growing up over there and
being the only
uh african-american kid
not being able to speak the language i
gravitated towards the game
and in that game you find a lot of um
you find solace in the game and then
when you play with kids that
might not uh accept you because you're
an outsider
but yet when we come to play the game
that's my chance to to
to get vengeance on them for not
accepting me and
and that's where it kind of started
developing and throughout the course of
my life it's always been that
it's always been the outsider and having
to come in and prove
you know or or to seek some sort of
vengeance swell boy you were so dominant
your whole career
one of the greatest of all time was
there a weakness that you had the
challenge for me was always
compassion and empathy because you're
like guys let's go
get results shut up don't complain right
i don't want to hear your whining i
don't want to hear it no excuses don't
tell me how rough the water is just
bring the boat in
you know like i don't i don't want to
hear it you know and it's uh
funny it's understanding like okay these
guys have lives
right out of here they have other things
happening other things happening to them
that may be affecting the way that
they're practicing
or the way that they're performing right
and it was hard for me to understand
that because
nothing bothered me you know anything
personally that
never phased me when i compartmentalized
it very well but so i couldn't
understand how
my teammates couldn't do that either
until i you know so i had to really work
on that aspect of it that's hard [ __ ]
do you have a mindfulness or meditative
practice that you used while you played
yeah well phil introduced meditation to
us when he came
to our team in 99 2000 and
it was something that i instantly
gravitated to because i could see
the effects right you i used to watch
you know studying the games the bulls
teams
and um you know watching their demeanor
watching their composure
playing in a tough place in like utah
doing the finals and being down 17.
but everybody was like this you couldn't
tell if they were down 17 or up 20 or
tie game
it never changed and i was wondering why
that is and that's why i started doing
more research and when phil
came i immediately gravitated to it and
then found myself
accepted the challenge of finding what
that space is and
for the 81 point game and to be honest i
was i wasn't even thinking about the
game my knee was hurting so much
um i didn't know then but you know i had
to flap a joint
of cartilage stuck in my joint line and
so my mind was really trying to
go to a place where i don't feel that
pain
and uh game started and because of that
i was just in a different space
you know i wasn't worried about what was
to come i wasn't worried about what just
happened i was just here
and when you're just there in the moment
playing plays right in front of you your
focus is heightened because
nothing else matters um and
that's the space i've tried to get to do
you remember what you told me
one day in the forum when i first met
you
you said you were going to be the finish
it for me like the greatest player of
all time
yes you remember you told me that no but
that sounds that sounds something
no it sounds like something that i would
say you actually
you actually said that and then you
actually said i'm gonna be the will
smith of the nba
you know i've always had ambition phil
will come to me and say there was a year
there in 03 where i had 40 points in
nine straight games
right shaq was out it was a toad
thing so phil comes to me before the
stresses kobe we need you to take over
the offense
i'm like all right cool so that's no
more i got it
i got it so that literally started the
streak
a 40 straight game you know 40 points in
nine straight games
shaq comes back from injury and phil
goes you know i still continue to do it
right and then phil
calls me to his office goes hey you know
we're starting to lose the big fellow
what do you mean well he's not getting
the attention you know this this
40-point streak
is starting to kind of take away his
fire to prove something
right so i need you to start dialing it
back i'm like what
he says we're going to lose him and we
need them in june
okay all right we have a game against
the clippers
yeah like 38 or something like that and
i had a chance to score 40 and get 40
again it's a blowout game like
dump the ball in the shack instead of
shooting a wide open shot the 40 point
streak ended that night
wow that was it and that's inside stuff
that people don't know
right you want people to go out and say
are you happy
yeah because phil was like hey we got to
dial it back gotta dial it back we're
starting to lose the big fight perfect
kobe too you're like he's like you gotta
dial it back you're like alright i'll
score 38 instead of 40.
well i mean it's a streak thing i
wouldn't it would have been ten or else
broke a record right
right right i would have broke the
record but instead you know reunite the
two of you back together again on
valentine's day
what's up young boy what's up man
so good to play with you again we did i
had flashbacks
felt great every game was real easy and
we read each other very easily
and um it was a it was fun to kind of
you know go back to memory lane you
believe him when he says was all me
deployed by him to grab attention and
take pressure off you big chief marketer
yeah you should say that all the time
you say that all the time
kobe bryant shaquille o'neal co-mvps of
all-star
2009. i know you're not exactly the
sentimental type but
when you guys are having the interaction
on the court feel like old times a
little bit does it make you
a little bit at all wistful for being
able to play with shaq having those
those moments
no
no but do you remember what you did
during that game to make me realize i
was were you all these years no you
don't remember
so we got the co-mvp it's me
sharif and you signed on stage what did
you tell me to do
he told me to take the trophy home i
tried you know that i did
and i took it home and i gave it to
sharif yeah and i realized that i was
like
i think i may have messed something up
because a lot of times that our beef was
going on you know me i'm the master
marketer
or 60 of the time i would just say it
just to keep it going
but like when you did that when you
didn't have to do that because you know
usually they take it and they mail it
right
like jack you know you know sharif loves
you
uh he goes sharif and you gave him a
trophy i
you know i just said myself that i was
like luckily i won three out of four
with this guy but i was up to this guy
so
i i owe you an apology i'm gonna give
you apology but we're gonna be doing all
that crime
but thank you for that moment because uh
sharif wrote that moment
that was the first time i was able you
know to give him something he was there
i was going through a lot at that time
and you know he loves you for it
i love you for that moment thank you
thank you
when you're going into the league you're
going with a lot of guys that were you
know
same same age you know same class as you
were going in
yeah were you sizing those guys at the
same exact way as you did in high school
i did but you know in the nba
it was actually easier because what i
found in the nba is a lot of guys
played for financial stability and when
they came to the nba they got that
financial stability
so therefore the passion and the work
ethic and the obsession
the obsessiveness was gone so i'm
looking at that i'm like
oh my god it's gonna be like taking
candy from a baby and i wonder mike wins
all these [ __ ]
championships this
is crazy you know what i'm saying and
like
and then you had the players that had
that passion
but weren't willing to commit
their entire lives to doing that right
it's a choice
right you have other things you have
family you have all these other things
you have to do
the game can't really be your number one
priority and so that's just looking at
that like man i'm
this is going to be fun you've always
gone at it what took you a while what
was something in your life that you were
shy about originally or
that took you a while to go head-on with
but then finally you got there and you
figured it out
uh riding dear basketball that was a
hard jump
you know because i had i'd written
before i mean i started writing
probably about 17 years ago so
practicing every day
a lot of things that i wrote were were
ads and so
you write an ad nobody looks up at who
wrote the ad right you can kind of
there's a certain
uh anonymity that comes along with that
right
but right there basketball was different
you know it's putting it out there for
the world to see it's trying to create a
short film
and uh i didn't know if i could do it
man and uh
you know it was my daughter who kind of
put things in perspective for me gianna
she's now 13 and she was like well
you know you always tell us to go for it
so
[Laughter]
yeah she put me on the spot she was like
you're gonna talk about it you're gonna
be about it basically and you know and
that that gave me the final push
that means taking things using things in
your life that
are scars using those moments as
a weapon right using those as you know
using basketball as kind of like a
vehicle
through which to express yourself right
so it doesn't so
at that moment for us to face the
celtics again it's not about the celtics
it's not about your opponent it's about
you it's about you
taking your inner struggles and
channeling that through the game
right as a as a as a way to to unleash
right so now it became a matter of how
do i express that to them how do i get
them to that point where
they figure this out for themselves
because i can't say hey listen i need
you to play harder
so what'd you do well i had to share my
story i had to open up to them and let
them know
i've dealt with things this is the
things that i use this is how i go about
focus this is how
i deal with adversity this is how i deal
with you know arguing with my wife
the day of the game and showing up to
the game and still having that focus to
be able to play like i
used those things to open up with them
and then in turn they were able to
um to to to take those stories
and and make them their own well you
just got to put one foot in front of the
other
and you know sometimes i think uh you
know even for myself it's easy to become
distracted a little bit and start trying
to look at the final
what the final picture is going to look
like and you know when you do that you
can you can easily become frustrated
with where you
are at the moment so um you know my
advice is just to focus on each day
and you know you have a plan in place of
how you want to improve and how you want
to get better
and you stick to that plan and trust the
fact that
you know every day that you you know um
stick to the plan it'll get you to your
end result
you know i mean if everybody wants to
compete and they think it's it's knowing
how to compete and also
you know um you know true competitive
instinct
really kicks in when you're down you
know like i said a lot of people are
competitive at things that
are rolling their way and you know um
things that they're naturally good at
you know but it takes a true competitive
person to
uh when things are down like this to
really step up to the plate and go out
go after it
now it's of utmost importance like i
mean i was such a die-hard fan
laker fan growing up man and just my
personality like it would
for me to ask for a trade or to go play
someplace else to try to
chase a championship that's not me man
that's not being that's not
what my career has been about that's not
who i am
you know i stay with it you know stuff
that i've been through in my life and
been through in my career
just taught me anything it's the fact
that you'll have good moments you have
bad moments you have great moments you
have horrible moments you just keep
going through all of them and then
things work themselves out and i've
always had
some of my best performances in the
world
[Applause]
you know when fans boo i absolutely love
it
i thrive they don't understand
who i
not only am i comfortable being an
outsider that has become a source of
motivation for me
so when i go to these places and you boo
it actually
comforts me yeah i think the best way to
prove your
your value is to work is to learn is to
absorb to be a sponge
but you always want to outwork your
potential
you know as hard as you believe you can
work you can work harder than that
and that's what i tried to do when i
first came in the league but you know
basketball is such a direct competition
sport
that me coming in at 17 i hated when
like my teammates would say you know i
get hit with an elbow right shaq would
hit me with elbow
in practice and like you know
you know nick van nextel will come up
and say are you okay
what am i are you okay
what's wrong with you you know so like i
always had that extra chip on my
shoulder so like every day in practice
for me was
really trying to annihilate everybody
that was that i was playing against
because i wanted to prove you don't need
to babysit me
like i'm fine you know and uh
and so it's always that competitive
nature
the work ethic and curiosity because i
asked a lot of questions
you know playing with byron scott i
asked him a lot of questions eddie jones
who was great at chasing guards off the
screens and i didn't understand
how to do that i would sit with him
before practice after practice
magic james worthy kurt rambis
kareem abdul all the laker greats i
would always sit down and just ask them
questions
about certain games that i studied
growing up what actually happened there
what did you feel there why
you know very tough to defend why
because you look slow to me
i'm like i'm missing something so like
tell me what i'm missing you know what i
mean
and so i would always ask questions and
try to learn as much as i could
a really critical time where i i had a
summer where i played basketball when i
was like 10 or 11 years old
and a very prominent summer league in
philadelphia called the sunny hill
league
where my father played my uncle played
and they were like all-time greats yeah
stuff and will chamberlain played in the
league you know
early pro-monroe playing league and here
i come
playing and i don't score one point the
entire summer
really not one how old were you 11 10
11.
and you're playing against other 10 11
year olds or you didn't score once not
one were you in the game i was in a game
how did you not score because that was
terrible really yeah
that happened 11 years old you were
that's awful i mean i you know and i had
these big knee pads on because i was
growing really fast and i had socks all
the way up here and i had like the
high top like skinny
and i scored not a free throw not a
nothing not a lucky shot not a breakaway
layup
zero points is that when you think the
mentality of hard work
started to come in for you at that age
when you failed
so miserably i guess that summer i think
that's when the idea of
understanding a long-term view became
important
because i wasn't going to catch these
kids in a week i wasn't going to catch
them in a year
right so that's when i sat down and said
okay this is going to take some thought
all right what i want to work on first
all right shooting all right let's knock
this out let's focus on this half a year
six months do nothing but shoot
right after that all right creating your
own shot and then you focus so you start
i started creating a menu of things
when i came back the next summer i was a
little bit better right yeah imagine
being like i've got my jump shot from 15
i've got yeah i got my jump shot from
15. i got my three-point shot like just
open shots not miss open shots right be
able to shoot it with speed because
those kids are so much more athletic
yeah
and then the next time i came back was a
little better the summer came back
somewhere it was a little better i
scored yeah it wasn't much right but i
scored and this is 12 13
12 13. then 14 came around back half of
13 14
years old and then i was just killing
everyone
and it happened in two years and i
wasn't expected to happen in two years
but it did
because what i had to do was work on the
basics and the fundamentals
well they relied on athleticism and
their natural ability
and because i stick to the fundamentals
it just caught up to them
and then my body you know my knee
stopped hurting i grew into my frame
and and then your athleticism once you
have the fundamentals exactly
the hard work the mindset and you attack
on the elections
and then it was game right wow so from
13
your good average still i was good i was
good and then about
about like the end of my third like
right when i was turning 14
i became the best player in the state 14
and 14. so from 12 to 14 you went from
scoring
zero to being the best in the state of
all ages
yeah i mean we talk about hard work all
the time it's like you know man if you
got to get up every single morning
remind yourself how hard you need to
work
you probably need to choose a different
profession you know
because that shouldn't be there i wake
up in the morning excited to get to it
you know if i'm not training i'm missing
it if i'm not watching the game of
basketball i miss it
you know there's no place i'd rather be
and if you have that feeling then you're
truly doing what
god has put you on this earth to do my
journey began
in philadelphia pennsylvania at the age
of three years old
my father putting the basketball in my
hands and me taking it from there
basketball was in kobe's blood his dad
is joe
jellybean bryant he played eight years
in the nba before
uprooting his family to take his career
overseas
as i grew older we moved to italy
while joe was getting used to playing in
europe his son was also making an
adjustment
in italy not many kids were perfecting a
jump shot
but kobe bryant was soccer was a big
sport
so they had goal posts underneath the
baskets on
concrete courts where kids used to play
soccer all day and
i would be one of them and then after
soccer i'd stayed here for another three
four five hours
just playing basketball it was a
different country
with a different language even though he
had his family
he was essentially alone
so kobe looked inward and developed the
relentless drive to work on his game
[Music]
when his family moved back to
philadelphia that time spent alone on
the court paid off
as kobe announced his arrival to the
basketball world he was the top high
school player in the country
breaking wilt chamberlain's scoring
records becoming a celebrity at 16.
kobe's next step may have seemed
ambitious but with his basketball
pedigree
and work ethic it was an easy decision
[Music]
i decided to feed my talent to uh
take my time to the aba
[Music]
kobe bryant now he's gonna be retiring i
remember season one
you said who is this kid his 20th season
all with the latest
greatest careers in basketball this will
not allow him to be
what he once was any longer
no one understands what it takes to be
great
the force that drives you to do what
others don't
the sacrifice is made all with one
purpose in mind
push yourself to become better
the extra seconds minutes hours of work
put into perfecting one's game
lifting yourself above the rest
to make sure your name will forever be
synonymous
with one word greatness
what does it take to be great work ethic
determination drive
takes ability it takes a desire baylor
moves on russell again
turns and puts up a tremendous field
goal i think it takes
years of players relying on you to take
the big shot
make the great play you know do the
things that
bring success to the team that's that's
what it's all about
it's getting out and measuring yourself
against others
and i think that when you have an
attitude like that
that's what i think that's part of
greatness
[Music]
at first i met kobe cove was just out of
high school
it was out here for a workout and i've
never seen anyone work out
as hard as this kobe i've never seen
anybody that prepared he was 17 years
old and
was ready to play nba basketball that's
that's pretty amazing i think jerry west
was
the one who said this he said i want
this kid because this kid had more
talent than anybody i have
planned for me right now and he had a
great team
just kidding would never take a night
off even if it wasn't
going well it was always going to be
trying to uh
slay the dragon if you don't have that
type of work ethic
you don't get to enjoy the benefits
[Applause]
in 2006 against the toronto raptors
you scored 81 points which is second
only to wilt chamberlain's
100 points you know i always dreamed as
a kid that
you know it was possible to score 80 or
90 or 100. i always just like
you know had a dream you know like
sometimes you lay down in bed and you
visualize things
you just kind of you know just you know
that's how that's at least how i would
go to sleep i'd
lay down i'd imagine playing for the
lakers and i would imagine what the
uniforms look like i would imagine where
we'd be playing
and you know the smell of the arena and
all sorts of stuff
and i would see myself you know getting
hot you know
score 10 straight points and then but in
the dream like why would you ever
interrupt that like you're not going to
have a dream and be like okay then he
misses his next six like it's not gonna
happen
so you just keep dreaming and dreaming
and dreaming and before i go to sleep
i'm like at 120 points
you know and so when you grow up
downloading that into your brain over
and over and over and then
you know that summer i made a thousand
shots a day
a thousand right that's on top of weight
training and my conditioning
i made a thousand shots and they weren't
just shots
it was shots that you saw in that game
there were specific shots somebody was
coming out of the corner going to the
pinch post footwork in the post coming
off the screen it was very specific
so when you download that into your
system and you go on in the court and
you're just
executing things that you've done
thousands of times before
and you have that dream then that
becomes possible
yeah everything's been not choreographed
but it's been practiced so many times
that
this second nature there's there's why
reinvent it
like i don't understand that you go out
and play the game
and you're just trying to create
something new
no no this is what i do this is what i
do extremely well
you're gonna have to stop me from doing
that and if you do stop me from doing
that i have a counter to that
done another thing you told me as an 18
year old i'm gonna be better than mike
so i knew it definitely drove you and
you know it's always going to be there
those comparisons when
somebody has come before you and you
deal with tim i mean i don't know if you
patted
the game after him or not i don't know
if you watched him in high school but
it was a lot of similarities but i know
i know that day you passed up michael
jordan i know you was probably riding in
your car like
you know what man i thought i would be
but like
what happened is when i came in the
league and i wanted to take them on
right i mean all i heard was you know
they called them black panther they
called
black jesus and all this stuff i want to
see what this is about
and um but what happened is that we
wound up
he wound up becoming a big brother i
know where you're going
you got to get up quickly if you knew
where i was going why you go for the
faith
right after you fake the ball where else
you lose off your feet yeah but
he saw something in me that reminded him
a lot of himself when he was coming up
he took me under his wing a lot and
showed me a lot of things taught me a
lot of things a lot of leadership things
kobe bryant passes the great michael
jordan and moves into third on the nba's
all-time scoring list so when i pass him
i remember talking to him
afterwards and saying you know this is
kind of it's it's
you know he's still here the information
and the stuff that he's passed on to me
i'm breathing that spirit back into the
game all over again
which is a lot of the reason why i try
to do that now for the next generation
because he did that for me bill russell
jerry west
[Music]
but michael in particular what does
losing feel like to you
oh it's exciting why is it exciting
um because it means you have different
ways to get better there are certain
things that you can figure out
that you can take advantage of right
certain weaknesses that were exposed
um that you need to shore up right so it
was exciting i mean
it sucks to lose but at the same time
there are is there if you just look at
them
um because you get the information from
losing more than from winning probably
yeah yeah i mean the answers are there
when you win too you you just have to
look at them
yeah right so it's a constant process
it's exciting when you win it's exciting
when you lose because the process
should be exactly the same whether you
win or you lose as you go back and you
look and you find things that you could
have done better
you find things that you've done well
that worked figure out how did they work
why did they work how can you make them
work again
yeah and uh but the hardest thing is to
face that stuff
that's a really really tough challenge
you mean face it you mean look yourself
in the mirror and say okay this is how i
showed up or this is what happened and i
give an example so
katie lou samuelsson is one of the best
college basketball players in the
country she plays at uconn she's going
to be a senior
right now right now and uh she's from
huntington beach
out here by us and so she comes down and
she works with some of my
my girls on the team and she helps coach
and yeah and
they just had a really tough season last
year where they lost to notre dame in
the final
that's right really tough first loss
first loss years right
and so i actually said have you watched
the notre dame game she was like
no well why not he said i don't want to
watch that i said i know you don't but
you're going to play notre dame this
year yeah yeah there's a chance that you
see him again
in the final well you'll probably see me
again i said well
you can't show up and play them without
knowing why you lost that one
right so you know the mistakes that
you've made in that game you have to do
the hard stuff
and watch that game and study that game
to not make those mistakes over and over
again
just because you weren't brave enough to
face it so she came down to the office i
brought down the office and we sat down
we watched that game together
right you gotta you gotta deal with it
face it
gotta deal with it face it learn from it
wow it must have been
cringing for her and she'd be like oh
you're playing like we could have won
all these things that's exactly it isn't
it i just did that one thing exactly if
i didn't get that foul if i scored that
layup
it's exactly right you're looking to say
oh there's the mismatch oh
there's the gap uh you know and all
those little things and it sucks but
but you don't want to have that feeling
again do you right so you got to really
study it
face it and uh not to say you'll win the
next time you face but you at least
you'll give yourself a better
better chance what are you most proud of
from your
20 seasons um
honestly it was sounds uh
may sound a little shallow but i gotta
say beating the celtics in game seven
um that's what i'm most proud of because
it was it was the hardest
um you know you're playing with
rajon rondo paul pierce kevin garnett
um all-star ray allen and you know
it was myself powell and players that
other teams didn't want
and you know how do we figure out as a
group what to do
and the reason why i love that series so
much is that we went down
three games to two against boston and
now you got two games coming home i
remember sitting in the locker room and
they beat the crap out of us too that
game so
we're sitting in the locker room and
it's really really quiet
i'm sitting there looking around and we
just lost the celtics and 08 so this is
like revenge right they're kicking our
butt again right so i sit around i just
started laughing
i started laughing and then i remember
uh derek fisher looked at me like
and lamar looked at me and goes what is
funny
i said dude they beat the crap out of
the bus
they just beat the crap out and say i'm
missing the part where that's funny
i said man listen if we start this
season and
they say you know all you have to do is
win two games at home
in your nba champ would you take that
yeah and like right yeah that's all we
got to do yeah
go down three two one two we're nba
champions all you gotta do is wait two
get two games in a row that's it
we'll take care of the first game and i
promise you
they're not winning game seven on our
home floor it's not happening so we all
just laughed about it
and then we went out and we figured it
out but that game seven was
we're down 15 points in the fourth
quarter right and that's when you have
to collectively look at each other and
say
you know the spirit of your team must be
good
because at that moment is when teams
fracture if the energy amongst
each other isn't there that trust isn't
there you're done
and we were able to collectively dig
deep together and say all right we're
going to figure this thing out
wow and i wasn't playing well i wasn't
shooting the ball well at all
um and so my teammates picked you up and
they delivered yes yeah wow the
storytelling for me is
the number one thing it's writing it's
outlined
it's creating uh narratives
that can inspire the next generation of
athletes
right what are those things and you know
and not from
uh merely a documentary perspective
but from a fantasy perspective from a
mythology perspective right what are
those stories that we can use
to teach the next generation of athletes
not just about the sport but teach them
about life through sport
how do we make those connections and so
that's what i obsess over every single
day
one thing what i loved about you as an
18 year old is is you wanted it
a lot of guys on our team didn't want it
but you wanted it at a
18 yard and that's why in the utah game
everybody talks about those air balls i
wasn't mad at you but kobe bryant for
three another air ball
he shoots back about their balls jazz
basketball
that's why i was the first one to come
grab you and say hey i know everybody's
laughing and giggling that but one day
people will fear you at the end of the
game so i knew that about you as 18 year
old
you know it was it was fun have you
noticed a moment where you're like i
can't
uh maybe i can't be as intense as i was
during sports i can't demand people to
be here until
midnight or practice without a ball for
three hours or
yeah no listen my my thing is really
simple here is that
you know i expect excellent work we all
do
so i don't care if you're here in the
office at
six a.m and you leave at midnight
if the work that you do is average then
this is not the home for you
conversely you cannot be in office at
all and have
excellent work this is the place for you
so i don't really care if you're here
there's a lot of guys that get in the
gym and work hard work hard work hard
work hard but then they can't transition
that to 7 30.
yeah right what it was like for you
with all of the grit and all of the
makeup that you had to be such a great
competitor
what was it like for you to play with
people that that weren't as gritty as
you were
how did you deal with that how did you
set your expectations knowing that
that you were so far out there and and
how did you deal with the players that
you played with you know knowing that
they
they were still kind of somewhere on the
spectrum but uh but you you're on the
top of it
good question that's a great question um
my response might
sound a little um tough
but i i just i'd kill him i bury him
um you know it's it's
you know tolerance for that and the
kind of culture that the laker
organization stood for winning
championships
is not tolerated you're going to show up
to play
and you're going to lollygag through
this scrimmage through this drill
i'm going to beat you i'm going to let
you know
i beat you i'm going to want you to
reconsider your professional life choice
you know and
and for the most part you know people
will say okay that doesn't make a great
teammate well i'm not here to be a great
teammate i'm here to help you win
championships
so there's a difference um
and you know fortunately for us and for
me you know we had an organization that
you know it was championships or nothing
and they were really good about
identifying that and bringing players in
here that had that competitive streak
and
you know getting rid of the ones that
did not if i got a fight to get you in
the gym
that's a problem that's a problem you
want players that are gym rats players
that
want to be in the gym that want to work
and then from there you build on top of
that
but if you're lazy man i don't want to
talk to you i won't deal with you you
don't make me feel dumber
you know you know you're going to lower
my level i don't think so
you can go over there there's plenty of
teams in here where you'll fit right in
you mentioned at the time they were
right down the hall from us
they were 96 through 99
was a frustrating point i don't know
about well
maybe a little bit for you but for me
being one of the best bigs in the league
and having that title of not winning one
they ain't got one yet right
i remember one day reading it reading in
the paper oh shaq's averaging 20 or 30
of
doing this and the great karim of
jujibar said well he didn't win that yet
right so is he great
and that just kind of i just kind of
yeah
you know well i i one thing that you
know um
i understood was your necessity to have
to win one
there's a lot of pressure and i think
there's a lot of frustration because you
kept seeing this kid
and everybody kept saying okay be
patient with this kid be patient with
this kid and you're saying
listen i don't have patience i have to
win now
and this kid needs to develop now i
think i can remember the
the first time we had our first fight um
and you looked and said okay this is
crazy i did say that yeah
anyway it was we're playing a pickup
game he's doing a lockout season
southwest college playing a pickup game
we're on opposite teams right and trash
talking
yes and you kept saying yeah take that
little take that little
i'm like i'm looking around
oh [ __ ] me yes right and i said well
hold on ain't gonna be too many more of
those
you know yeah remember what'd you say
what you're going to do about it what
you going to do about it
and then that's the next thing i knew i
saw a big hand coming this way
and i remember going this way i remember
throwing some lollipop
holding polynesia and then they all just
kind of broke us apart
broke us up i'm looking at this and i'm
saying
but he wants this thing he's it's it
affects him
right i mean he's it consumes him
and then from that moment on i knew we
spoke the same language doesn't matter
if we had disagreements and saying the
other our drive
to win like we have to win there's just
no other option
now we're going to figure this out we're
going to get this done and uh
and we did portland has three timeouts
left the lakers have two
brian
how would you explain that mindset of
just trying to continuously improve
i enjoy what i do you know this is fun
for me you know i i
truly love what i do and i'm that's
where the passion comes from that's
where the will to get better comes from
is just because i truly enjoy it i enjoy
the preparation
your high school coach greg donner
says that you might actually be a little
embarrassed by
how much you love basketball yeah
is that true probably yeah i mean it's
like well i mean it's like anything you
know i
i just so happened to be playing
basketball like if i was a
computer kid you know in high school
people would have probably made fun of
me you know what i mean and it just so
happened to be basketball what i'm
passionate about and
my passion knows no boundaries but it
embarrasses you well i mean it's just a
little weird little strange i mean when
you're around like
in the olympics i'm around other
athletes who kind of share that same
that shame mine same mindset it's it's
fun to be around them because you can
have conversations about those things
i know it's good to say that you want to
win the championship every year but it
probably wasn't really a realistic one
so
how do you would adjust how do you
adjust as a team leader
and then how what conversations does
ownership have with the coaches
and teams about rebuilding genie is so
sweet
that she saw me work so hard for so many
years
and the last few years
her rob who was at the time my agent
called me and said listen we are so
sorry for what happened
to this team we're sorry that we don't
have seriously it's like we don't we're
sorry we don't have
a team around you that can contend for a
championship i mean
you know it's um so
we can make a few calls and get you on a
contending team
uh if that's something because we just
feel horrible about seeing you going out
there and struggle remember this
and i said then i listen i said you know
we've known each other for a very long
time
now i'm questioning myself because i'm
wondering what about me makes you think
i would jump ship
i've been a laker fan since five years
old man
i know the laker history all the way
from minneapolis all the way to where it
is today
right so it's in my blood in this family
her father um
believing in me and standing by me and
also stuff like i'm not
not gonna go anywhere like this is home
to me you know we work through this
stuff together and like
you know as a leader you gotta be able
to take the good with the bad man you
can't just
because the ship's sinking all of a
sudden i'm gonna jump off and swim to
another ship like that
you don't do that right if you can win
championships in front of everybody
then you can miss the playoffs in front
of everybody you gotta be able to take
both sides of it
i remember the first practice we had
travis knight on the team
and uh i mean you proceeded to just
annihilate this kid and you know just
from everything
from talking trash to him to you know he
was
afraid to get on the bus and um one
thing that i noticed about you from the
jump
was that you didn't respect people that
you could bully and respect them
and you test them and you'd see what
they let you get away with and you'd see
if they would fold to that and that was
the first thing i observed
about you and that competitive fire that
you had
and then it all started making sense to
me that's how i see him play with that
rage when it comes out that's how i see
guys
when he plays they back away from
because they're fatal they're afraid of
that
that confrontation that physicality and
uh
and then i remember you taking me down
to jerry's deli
back in the day we had the big big flip
phones you know what i mean
i didn't have one though you have one i
said man i ain't getting one of those
man that's pretty damn cool
you know the big joint and just hanging
out with you man and uh
you showing me the ropes from day one
what are the characteristics that you
you're looking for to bring into your
team is it much like you want a teammate
for the lakers those type of
or what are you what are you looking for
specifically yeah the most important
thing is curiosity first
i want curious people people that ask
questions that want to figure things out
figure out new ways to do things you
know that's the most important thing
and then from that curiosity having the
determination to see that curiosity
through
right to figure out those steps if you
figure out okay this is a particular
course of action that we feel like we
should be taking
has it been done before no but that's
exciting to me let's figure it out
those are the characteristics that i
look for the final question is what's
your definition of greatness
i think the definition of greatness is
to inspire the people next to you
yeah i think that's what greatness is or
should be it's not
something that's that that lives and
dies
with one person it's how can you inspire
a person
to then in turn inspire another person
that inspires another person
and that's how you create something that
i think lasts forever yeah and
i think that's our challenge as people
is to um
is to figure out how our story can
impact others and motivate them in a way
to create their own greatness
what did you know and learn at the end
of your career
that you wish you knew at the beginning
understanding empathy and compassion
right
because as a young kid when i came in
the league it was like i'm driving this
way
and either you're going to be on the
train or be on the track
right where there was no such thing as
understanding that people have lives
outside of the game
which apparently i did not um
but like if i understood at an early age
it helps me as a leader to communicate
better
i came to understand that later
and getting to know people on a personal
level
um what are their fears where are their
insecurities right what are their
dreams and ambitions desires those sorts
of things
when you come to understand that about a
person then you can help them
reach the best version of themselves so
i wish i'd
known that earlier my favorite kobe
moment is
[Music]
in the finals in indiana i file out
rose's 20-foot jumper no good rebound
should be shacked
smith's got it loose ball fouls jack is
out of the game
i'm like damn i let the team down again
and you
and you put you and you put your hand on
my shoulder don't worry big fella i got
it
and you just and you took over kobe
fires the jumper
and gives la the lead shaw
running one-hander by
kobe bryant
[Applause]
or you can just feel the tension in this
building reggie
off the screen for three reggie for the
win
no and that's it the lakers
take a 3-1 series lead
it doesn't get any better than this ever
always knew you was a bad cat but that
moment right there because you had no
fear i was like
well you know i knew how much it meant
to you right now as
brothers you don't let you you don't let
your brother down right it wasn't my
time yet
this championship was yours right
because you have worked hard
to get us to this point right for your
whole career in orlando and all the
disappointments and here you are
and it's my responsibility to pick that
up was it a hard decision
like i'm going pro or did you just know
because a rod obviously did the same
thing
yeah um you know as a young kid 17
18 going to be a pro athlete it was uh
it was a tough decision i i
you know ultimately um
the key factor for me was wasn't whether
or not i was ready
it was the fact that if i wasn't ready i
was determined to figure out how to get
ready
and ultimately even if i was ready
i still need to improve anyway right so
the work's not going to stop
it was just a matter of do you want to
come to the league and learn from the
best and i'm doing the math in my head
i'm looking at
stockton how many years he's playing
drexler how many years he's playing
mj how many years more he's playing
hakeem these are players that i studied
growing up
and the best way to learn from them is
to have that jump off of the film
jump off of the page and see it face to
face
that's the best way to learn because i
had it was like a database i had
everything in my mind
what they could do what they didn't like
to do where they did it when they did it
now if i could see that up close that is
the greatest form of education that i
could possibly receive
so that's when i was like nah i'm gonna
i'm gonna go pro you have a brand you
have a shoe
um but you've chosen to do something
else something
that's that's more bold something that
you really haven't done before
can you tell us why you're doing this
why you're going into a creative
endeavor like granity studios
um because i love doing it i mean it's
that simple
you know you have to sit and ask
yourself what is truly going to get you
up in the morning it's going to keep you
up at night
and you know when you find what that
answer is you stay true to that
you know i've built the brand for the
last 20 some years personal brand which
is great
but that is not where our focus is going
to be for the next 50 years
right it's what we are doing now are we
taking a big risk
yeah but i think that if we focus
on one thing and do that one thing
exceptionally well
we won't fail at that one thing so
sometimes you got to put the other stuff
to bed and focus on what you believe
is is uh is the core of the company
and that always starts from what you
love to do the most what most people
don't know is our story goes back when i
met you um
in orlando in orlando you guys said
we're playing the pacers in the playoffs
in 94
and i came to a game and you know penny
back then was my
role model and i looked up to him quite
a bit
asked to take a picture with him he kind
of brushed me off i remember that yeah
and i came to you guys take a picture
and you were like hey come here young
fella yeah where you from
you know i remember and uh that's when
the first time i met you i don't know if
you know this but
i was in atlanta still with the orlando
magic
uh we get a call from from jerry west
and my agent 2am me and jerome we're out
of the club
jerry west says i got what you want at
that time i was asked for 150 i know i
was gonna get 150 but jerry got me 120.
so he called me up to the room and he
put the
piece of paper on there and before i
could sign he stopped me
he said let me tell you something i just
acquired this kid from charlotte
you and him gonna get about three or
four championships i was like what are
you talking about say kobe brown's like
oh
cool i wasn't worried about nothing i
was just trying to get you there once
when you're gonna try to get to that
120.
and that was the first time i i knew of
your greatness
and then when you came in he was 18 he
was doing a lot and i can remember i can
remember one time
in the three-on-two drill you came out
on sean rooks and you put them into your
ding ding ding ding
dale kobe what did you gonna be a great
player but don't have to do that again
the people that i've always had issues
or problems with
other people that don't demand
excellence for themselves
i won't tolerate that except then when
the career is said and done
they're not going to be looking at you a
player on this team and saying
you didn't win a championship no doing
me looking here
right so it's my responsibility to make
sure everybody's holding themselves
accountable i'm holding you accountable
if we just played a back to back
and we have practice the next day your
ass better be there tape ready to go
right cause i'm there and i'm ready and
i just got finished lifting weights for
two hours
right so i hold guys to a higher
standard i was wondering if you've had
to tone down your competitiveness and
your approach in a new work environment
um yeah yeah um
more than a little bit yeah no it well
like i said basketball is different
because it's such a direct
competition um what we do now there
isn't the competitiveness
that i um bring to work every day is
really helping people
in a sense be competitive with
themselves right if you're if you're
animating something or or um
you're writing a screenplay or you're
composing a piece of music
is that the best you can do right don't
ask me
don't say okay do you approve don't ask
me i'm not the musician i'm not the
composer you know
right so the competitiveness is more
from an individual perspective
are you is this the best you can do and
uh if the answer is yes then off we go
so it's different for me it was it was
kind of the perfect series playing the
celtics you know
then beating us in 08 and then you know
having five i mean we joke about that a
lot but the most important thing was
beating the celtics because of
everything that they meant to this
organization
it was a tough series for me most people
don't know this but i had a bone spur in
my ankle
and then a couple games in boston i had
to leave the game
go back in the locker room and get it
injected because i could barely walk
i had a broken finger i was playing with
it had to cast my right finger
and then i was having to deal with
garnett
pierce ray allen rondo rashid why i mean
all these guys and having to try to
figure out how to get through that
series and so
um it was a big relief to win
first and foremost relief to win and get
out of that series allowed if i lost to
the celtics man i
i've been miserable trivial things
weren't going to pull my attention
it had to be things weren't going to put
my attention it had to be things that
were
i had a purpose i wanted to be one of
the best basketball players to ever play
and anything else that was outside of
that lane
i didn't have time for at at what age
did that goal become crystal clear
i made that deal with myself at 13 years
old at 13 years old 13 years old that's
the deal i mean clear about it crystal
clear and where did inspiration come
from
um the love of the game the love of the
game the challenge like i would watch
magic play i'd watch michael play
and i would see them do these
unbelievable things and i said you know
can i get to that level i don't know but
let's find out do you think one of the
edge you had over everybody else was
the biggest percentage of your focus was
on one thing
do you see it that way like that was my
edge over everybody else
i do um at the time i didn't really
understand that
right so you know basketball for me was
the most important thing so everything i
saw whether it was tv shows whether it
was books i read
people i talked to everything was done
to try to learn how to become
a better basketball player everything
everything and so when you have that
point of view
then literally the world becomes your
library
to help you to become better at your
craft i read a story that you used to
play
uh guys to a hundred you did you'd be
like you have to stay in this gym
and play me to a hundred and i mean what
was the biggest margin of victory you'd
ever win at
uh well in high school i used to spike
guys 99
no kidding um but you know listen these
practices
practices are meant to be competitive
they're meant to be competitive
if your practices aren't more
competitive than the games themselves
you're doing the wrong thing and most of
these teams and coaches have gotten into
a mindset of
resting players oh it's too much
you know we're not gonna practice light
day light day light day phil never gave
us a light day
there's no days off you show up and you
work and you practice yeah
and practices are going to be worse it's
going to be more physical
there's going to be more trash talking
and i'm going to let you know
right if you're going to show up today
i'm going to let you know and it's going
to be embarrassing
and you're gonna hate it um but when
game seven rolls around the nba finals
you will be prepared
how do you see dance and other art forms
and athletics in alignment with one
another
well um there was a there was a year i
played um
indiana pacers in the finals i rolled my
ankle really bad
jaylen rose stepped under me on purpose
he admits it now finally drove my ankle
really really bad i came back finished a
series
but i couldn't touch a basketball until
mid-september
which was driving me crazy so i couldn't
train but i looked at this was like the
tenth time i rolled my ankle in one
season
so i'm looking at that i'm saying okay i
gotta address that and so
being that i couldn't get on the
basketball court um
what i did was i took tap dancing
lessons okay no kidding
i took tap and tap was like the best
training for me in the world because the
strength in my feet
it changed my rhythm and my approach to
the game i was able to change speeds
when i came back the following season
um you know i think dancers
put way more strainer in their body than
athletes do
and i think there's a lot that can be
learned from that my daughter took
ballet for
several years and i was sitting there in
the class right and i didn't know what i
was getting into because i don't know
anything about ballet right but i'm
sitting there in the class
and i'm watching her and watching to get
the first position the second position
i'm learning the structure and the rules
that go along with that
and as athletes there's a lot to be
learned from that because if you simply
go out there and perform and play
yeah you'll be great every now and then
but if you play with structure
if you understand the rules that come
along with that the discipline that
comes along with that
then you reach another level but you
guys have my respect if
other people don't see that there that's
on them thank you
what habits allow you to consistently
come through in the clutch
and specifically when it matters most
just be calm
just be calm you know sometimes we tend
to over
hype situations you know kind of
our imagination gets in our own way yeah
you know
at the time you know brian d wade a lot
of those guys especially brian was still
young yeah and hadn't really figured out
those pressure situations
and for me i was able to detach myself
from it
and and to allow and
to allow the work that i put in that
practice to manifest itself
during the game right so there's no need
to panic like i've
taken these shots thousands and
thousands of times before nothing
changes
yeah i've had games that i've won games
that i've lost at the buzzer
you show up the next morning and you get
to practice again anyway
right right so not getting in your own
way
if i'm buddies with you from high school
if i'm a cousin of yours
what happened to our relationship how
did that gravitate when you went into
the league and you're
you're determined to become the greatest
so you're determined to become one the
greatest
what happens to our relationship well it
suffers it does suffer oh yeah
okay yeah and you understood that you
were okay with that well yeah
and the people that love you like
friends and family like they know that
about you
got it so they let you be you and when
you reconvene
you know you pick back up where you left
off but make no mistake about it
everything in between is lost right so
those
long-term relationships the commitment
of time of
uh you know uh taking vaca like i see a
lot of players
take vacations with other players that
are close friends
and i'll just take vacations just to
take vacations or just hang out just to
hang out like i
i'm not i never did that
why why didn't you do that well because
when i retire i didn't want to have to
say
i wish i would have done more i don't
want that
in today's nba i mean you see a guy like
kevin durant go to golden state
yeah you would never have made that move
no i wouldn't have but you know
different strokes for different folks
man i you know when i was coming up it
was
kobe can't win without shaq but i've
never heard that argument made about
magic and kareem
right or michael and pip right but that
was the
that was the thing being thrown my way
and i was like all right well
it is what it is let's see you were born
in philadelphia yeah
you spent quite a bit of your time uh as
a child in italy
yep right uh what was it like having to
move away from the states
learn a new language and how did that
experience play a role
in who you ultimately became well it was
uh you know
when we moved i was six and
my sisters were seven and eight and at
the time we didn't know anything
right right we were in philadelphia we
didn't know much you know our parents
kind of tricked us into saying well
you know at the age of 12 you could ride
around on like a moped
and drive around that got us excited
about moving to it right so
um but once we moved over there it was
amazing because we didn't really
understand
you know kind of the the shift that was
occurring
you know you get there you're
immediately put into an italian school
right where nobody speaks english and
you have to adapt you have to adapt you
have to adjust
and i think it had a way of opening our
minds
a little bit more to what's possible
and being able to or being willing and
comfortable to adapt to new things
who were some of the guys that you saw
and you watched that weren't just driven
by the money were there some names that
you looked at and says
these three guys are as crazy as i am i
do
i at the time i deal with what i've
referred to as
goat mountain i went to goat mountain
and i talked to magic michael
byrd kim olajuwon jerry west
oscar robinson bill russell
you know so i would talk to them
what did you do what were your
experiences michael in particular he's
become my big brother
he's been my big brother since i first
came in the league and
what was that process like so i went to
them and started understanding
the ins and outs of the game and you
know how they approach
things and their level of detail and
obsessiveness and
um that's what i did how did you get
that mentality of just being like
i need to get over this like i need to
get over myself you know trial and error
you know you grow up and you make
game-winning shots and it's awesome
you come back the next day and miss a
game when it's shot and it's misery
and then the next day comes and you're
back playing again and you understand
that life has this cyclical nature where
it's
you know what you do on monday it's
fantastic but then tuesday's a bad day
but guess what there's wednesday
so are we just supposed to live our
lives like this the whole time you know
versus just staying like this and
understanding that it's really just a
journey of
evolution every day it's just constant
improvement constant curiosity
constantly getting better
the results don't really matter uh it's
the
figuring out that matters yeah and we
all get obsessed about the results
yeah like we get obsessed about like the
output yeah not the input of not
figuring it out and not like changing
things well you said trial and error
like the experimenting
yeah we forget to do that it's
unfortunate man like i've seen a lot of
players
um especially now you know in youth
basketball dealing with that
um you have players that are like bigger
and faster and stronger and you know
their coaches are just coaching them
for results you know we're just going to
use your size that because you're bigger
than every other 12 year old out there
to dominate today and but they're not
growing
right so they're just based on that
result but they're not focused on
growing this young
child yeah into becoming a better
athlete and through that
teaching them how to become a more
well-rounded person
and we're missing that now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
question of the day i want to know what
is the single greatest lesson you
learned today from kobe bryant
let me know put it down the comments
below and if you made it this far in a
video you're still here watching i want
to celebrate you because believe nation
we don't just watch videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're gonna take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you three
two one remember
in your jersey retirement and i'm
walking out
and we were in the playoff race in the
hunt and going south
they were walking out and i gave you
dexter man i love you you know
congratulations everything and i was
just you know
happy for you you know but i couldn't
help but say you know this night
has made a lot sweeter because i know
you have four and i have five
oh yeah
this type of duo i don't think you'll
ever see it again
never ever ever
made it
none of that none of that hold on we
gotta take a picture
give him five and give me four
one left you get them all in the picture
if you want more fire content from les
brown check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and i'll
see you there